guys bangbang I'm sitting here with the
man the myth the legend Allen is here
and just first of all thank you so much
for coming to do this I know for those
that don't know silver gate recently
went public and he has been on the road
for two plus weeks telling a story after
story and fundraising so he's pretty
topped out at this point thanks for
coming to do this yeah absolutely happy
to be here thank you thanks for the
opportunity for sure let's get started
with just your personal story kind of
what you did free silver gate then we
can get into the crypto stuff
sure so actually started in banking as a
teller while I was in college and so
over the last almost 40 years I've done
just about every job that you can do in
the bank me and I did spend some time in
private industry in the 1990s in both
retail and manufacturing and so actually
ran companies that needed banking
services and then in the late 90s got
back into banking and it was a business
bank and so really liked being back on
the other side of the table helping
businesses and as we were just talking
about one thing I know being having run
a business and then being back in making
businesses just want their bank to work
they just don't want to think about it
right and so our whole goal is if we can
just make it seamless for our customers
to you know to kind of do their business
and not have to worry about their bank
but anyway so done that for most of my
career I joined silver Gate in 2008
right at the height of the financial
crisis and what attracted me to silver
gate was it was a very clean but small
platform that I thought was gonna be
really good to build a foundation on and
little did I know that around that same
time that I was that I was joining
silver gate there was also this this
this white paper you know being written
about Bitcoin I didn't know anything
about it you know I'm not a cyber Punk
and so we just went about building the
bank and because we were clean during
the financial crisis coming out of that
we could lend when a lot of other banks
were struggling and so so for the first
few years we were growing like crazy on
the asset side making loans and
ironically what we were struggling with
was we were struggling with growing the
deposit side of the balance sheet to
fund our loan growth what why is that a
challenge at the time yeah it was really
just just because first of all silver
gate was not well known and so brigate
didn't really have a deposit franchise
if you will we had four branches kind of
spread out all over Southern California
didn't really have a brand name and and
then at that time if if if you were a
business and you had a banking
relationship you didn't want to lose it
because there was so much turmoil you
know coming out of the financial crisis
and so it was really difficult to kind
of you know shift people's mindset to
leave their bank and join a new one and
and so you know and that's certainly
understandable so we just kept on
lending and you know we were finding
creative ways to fund the loans you know
opening CDs and you know doing a little
internet banking and some of that you
know some of that stuff and then along
the way in 2013 I started reading about
Bitcoin and what I and it was just
intellectual curiosity at that point I
wasn't really thinking about it and how
it might intersect was silver gate it
was just kind of in my spare time I you
know I read stuff yeah and and we were
looking for deposit niches for the bank
and I was reading about Bitcoin and I
was reading that there were companies
that were being formed to provide
infrastructure to this new thing called
Bitcoin it wasn't called crypto you know
it wasn't you know it was just like it
was Bitcoin only at the time and and so
I learned that there were companies they
were raising venture money so they had
deposits they wanted to put them in a
bank
so regrets bank and they were getting
kicked out of there
banks and and so obviously there was a
reason they were getting kicked out and
and it was the perception of risk right
it would talk a little bit more about
that perception Riggs I think this is a
key piece where if you don't pay
attention to Bitcoin and crypto in daily
basis and the other industry in the
world may be other than cannabis banking
is a you know readily available if
you're in developed country as you're
saying that wasn't true in 2013 and
actually it wasn't true for a pretty
long period of time right why were other
banks getting rid of these crypto or
Bitcoin companies and what was that risk
they proceeded sure so there were there
were two things from a regulatory
perspective one was just a general sense
in the United States where banks were
kind of de-risking money service
businesses check cashing companies
payday lenders you know there there was
there was this this whole kind of
movement in the from the larger banks
away from providing banking services to
those money service businesses and if
you think about companies that were
being formed at the time you know
example I use off in his coin base right
so coin base is a money transmitter and
money service business and so they were
struggling to find bank accounts because
lots of banks were kind of just they
were leaving that that segment so that
was that was one reason the other reason
was because of the whole concern about
any money laundering
BSA and that really has more to do with
kind of terrorist financing you know bad
actors and you know it's it was right
around that time that Silk Road happened
right and and so big concern that the
primary use case for Bitcoin at the time
was for a you know nefarious activity
right and and what people didn't really
understand at the time was that well you
know if you're using Bitcoin for you
know that kind of stuff you've got a
higher probability getting caught right
and and so that was a little bit of an
aha moment for us early on because when
I so I was reading about Bitcoin read
about Silk Road
read that companies were getting kicked
out of banks I thought well here there
might be an opportunity for silver gate
but the first thing you know we're a
regulated financial institution where a
state chartered bank in California where
remember the Federal Reserve our
deposits are insured by the FDIC and so
we had a lot of regulatory oversight and
still do and so the first thing I did
was was called our compliance officer
and I said hey have you heard about
Bitcoin and the great thing was she had
oh really yes so she's not our chief
operating officer her name is Kate for
air and and Kate immediately sent me
articles you know and and so and it's so
cool because at silver gate we just
we've got this culture and and it's just
a whole bunch of folks who are curious
who were you know reading about stuff in
their spare time and so you know so we
started a dialogue and I said well do
you think we can figure out how to bank
these companies because it might be a
source of deposits and that was as
simple as it was we've become a lot more
you know a lot more sophisticated and
our account offering to our customers
but in the early days it was just was
just here's a niche that is no one else
wants to serve if we could figure out
how to serve them but also kind of pay
attention to the risk yeah then we can
drive deposits Drive deposit we can
continue to fund loans chrome assets
that's right that's kind so let's fast
forward a little bit as you grew that
business the first customer is somebody
that you guys had actually known for a
while let me tell the story a little bit
of mature who that first customer was
yeah I don't come together yeah so so
it's funny how how things in life works
so so probably two or three years
previous to that I had met this company
by the name of second market and second
market was founded by Barry Silver and
and and his claim to fame or the way I
heard of him it was they were making a
market for illiquid securities kind of
pre IPO so making a market for Facebook
stock before Facebook went public
okay and the reason our paths crossed
and I didn't meet Barry at the time I
met someone who worked who worked for
him but I think they had a thesis that
okay we're there
other markets where there might be
illiquid securities are you know illa
liquid ownership people that want that
want liquidity and there's all these
privately owned independent banks across
the country and so so that's how we met
silver gate up until a week ago who was
a privately owned company and so so we
met we talked about maybe doing
something together
and that never really took off
little did I know that I think Barry was
already kind of starting to pay
attention to Bitcoin but what what the
intersection there was I think
SecondMarket got to know us as a bank
that was maybe willing to look at things
a little differently and and we've just
kind of had this this process or this
this methodology of looking at risk
whether it was what is the perception of
the risk versus the actual risk because
oftentimes there's there's a you know
and that's the whole thing about Bitcoin
to write on but if the perception of
risk is here that you can mitigate that
risk and the risk is really here then
all of this is opportunity yeah I talked
about mispricing risk all time so yeah
absolutely and and so so that's that's
the way we looked at Bitcoin and and so
in 2013 all of a sudden we start getting
referrals from second market for
companies in the Bitcoin space and and
just coincided with with us looking at
it and so so in January of 2014 our very
first customer in this space was second
market there now known as Genesis
trading and the whole you know very sold
second market to NASDAQ and created the
digital currency group and so what what
started as one account with with second
market that became Genesis is you know
is now you know we we are their bank and
they've made a lot of investments in
companies over the years and
those companies are not clients that
silver gate as well it's amazing and and
it's so funny how very and digital
currency group have become a very
important part of the ecosystem but in
the very early days obviously you know
kind of being that first customer I
think probably gave you some confidence
and hey look at least we got one person
to do this well yeah and and the other
thing that was important is is because
we are regulated you know we have to
make sure that we're doing everything
right and and so going and banking
second market because of the fact that
they were Broker Dealer so we knew that
they were familiar with regulation they
understood kyc know your customer they
understood BSA at the Bank Secrecy Act
am l année money laundering all of those
things they had to do that for their for
their customers as well so we looked at
it as like providing banking services to
another regulated company but the cool
thing was that we also went to school
right away on understanding what it was
they were doing so so in order for us to
get comfortable that so let's say that
second market was facilitating the
buying or selling a Bitcoin between you
know between two parties and the and the
US dollars we're going to go across
silver gate banks wire system right so
what we were doing in January 2014 as we
were asking for the second market hey
for that transaction that you're sending
that wire provide us the blockchain
address so that because we want to do is
go to a block explore you know and we
want to type in that address we want to
see a transaction that represents the
dollars that's going through the bank
and I think they were they were kind of
surprised that a bank was even asking
that question in 2014 for sure and so
today like you go from that first
customer to maybe share a little bit
about just like where you guys are from
assad's I know in the Prospectus you
guys have shared a bunch of this but
more than 800 customers today and kind
of just talk about where you got into it
with the business yeah I mean we can go
into kind of what those products are
sure so yeah today we we have
close to 800 customers it started small
obviously and I think by the end of 2016
we still only had a couple dozen
customers but importantly there were
some of the the most well known
companies you know that still exist
today and so back in the day you know we
we were you know we got to meet all the
crypto oh geez before anyone knew they
were oh geez right you know and there's
people looking for bank accounts and so
we were just very blessed you know I
mean I will say there's certainly an
element of luck you know and an element
of just kind of being opportunistic but
we ended up you know banking some of the
best most well-respected companies in
this little ecosystem and and then in
2016 we hired the other really important
person in this story for just you know I
mean they're our first let me say there
are over 200 employees at silver gate
who every day come to work figuring out
how to just kind of kill it for our
customers you know I mean it's it's just
it's a pleasure to work with them Ben
Reynolds is a guy that we met I met him
in January I think of 2016
okay he knew nothing about Bitcoin and
like most people yeah absolutely and we
were just looking for somebody to help
us you know kind of what should we be
doing next right we had a couple dozen
customers maybe 40 50 million in
deposits
the bank was about maybe six hundred six
to eight hundred million in assets
okay so deposits didn't even represent
ten percent of the assets at the time
and but we had great customers and and
so Ben you know what he did was he what
just went out to our customers and said
hey I'm new explain to me what you do
and you know how can we be more helpful
and it was out of that dialogue that the
son was born that what you know up it's
we would call it the silver gate
exchange Network most of our customers
call it the cen center se and silver
gate exchange now actually
yes thank you and you know some of the
people listening they won't get that so
yeah so so the idea was born really out
of talking with our customers about the
pain points that they experienced the
friction the banking friction getting
money into and out of the crypto
ecosystem and even though we were
helping them do that some of our
customers you know especially the
exchanges they wanted to be able to do
that at scale okay so how does that work
at scale well you really need to build
an API and there are a lot of companies
a lot of banks in the country that have
api's for doing things like pulling an
account balance or transaction history
there's probably less than two dozen
banks in the u.s. that actually have a
transactional API that will allow you to
transfer value and and so that was the
really kind of a aha moment for us is
that we've got a lot of customers who
are actually transacting with each other
but without the ability to do that in a
programmatic way and so it's really time
consuming so first we had to upgrade our
core data processing system which we did
in 2016 we then started building the API
and then in 2017 we started connecting
people to each other our customers to
each other and that timing again talked
about luck because in 2017 we were
really poised when the market took off
yeah and we went from you know having
less than you know a couple dozen
customers to having a little over 200
customers by the end of 17 we grew we
doubled the size of the Bank of the Year
now that was the you know that was the
bull market of 2017 and but but again
it's important that you guys were doing
that's what you've been doing all along
you're offering banking services to
folks that were playing by the rules
doing the right things in crypto and at
the same time even in 2016 and 17 just
like it just in 13 other banks were
still uncomfortable they were still
shutting them off they were still taking
people out and so I think when I first
heard hey silver date is you know kind
of friendly to this it
thank God we have them right because
where else are we gonna go if there's
not silver gate there wasn't very many
options at the time sure I'll see you
guys benefited from having done the work
upfront yeah kind of being open-minded
and working with those companies is an
obviously doing a good job because the
reputation spread and the business took
off yeah yeah I appreciate that yeah so
so we yeah we I still I just feel very
blessed that that that the timing worked
out in such a way that we were working
on this and that we were in the right
place at the right time and then
obviously doing the right things but
that gets back to the team you know back
back at the at world headquarters you
know of silver gate in La Jolla but
they're living in Southern California
they're they're there it's cold here in
New York this morning and I'm thinking
about what are you doing here when you
could be in Southern California yeah so
alright so anyone who's part of this
silver gate exchange Network talk about
like what changes for them from like a
user experience standpoint what like
what functionality does the network
actually give them yeah so what's the
value yeah so so if you're a if you're a
member of the San you can transact with
other members of the cen 24 hours a day
seven days a week 365 days a year
and you you're transmitting fiat
currency you primarily US dollars
although we have open this up for other
fiat currencies as well and your money
is there instantly so so it's like venmo
for corporations we joke about this one
of the guys back at the office jokes
that that his primary role in life is is
to connect this 1970s legacy banking
technology to the 24/7 you know crypto
market but I believe we you know we're
we were the first bank in the world and
I'm not sure if anyone else is doing
this yet but to be able to take the
legacy banking system that only operates
you know 40 hours a week Monday through
Friday and bring it into the 24/7 crypto
market that never sleeps and and this
becomes really important if if you are a
and it's too
investor you know I'm and I should say
this we we have an institutional focus
so when we talked earlier about the
almost 800 customers that's broken down
into three categories the first category
would be exchanges OTC desks etc and
then we connect them with institutional
investors these are family offices hedge
funds folks that are that are
approaching digital currencies as an
asset class okay and so they're they're
employing different investment
strategies and what they want to do is
they want to have confidence in their
banking relationship but then
importantly if we can make it efficient
for them to use their capital to get on
and off of different platforms and not
just in the US but around the world so
you know we we started obviously as a
us-centric operation but you know we
have customers internationally and so if
you if you wake up on a you know early
Saturday morning or Sunday morning or a
holiday and you see that something's
going on the crypto market in Asia and
you want to put some money to work you
can do it log into your account at
silver gate push some money over onto
whatever exchange you know you're
working with or call your OTC desk you
know and say hey you know I want to buy
or sell and you can do it just like that
and and so it's it's really been a game
changer for our customers and then that
has just really just kind of helped grow
the business because many of our
customers they don't want to trade with
others unless they're on the sand
because we just take out the friction
there is literally no friction now it
really is the true kind of network
effect right in the sense that once
somebody comes over then they want all
of their partners to come over right
once those jobs right over you get more
people to come into d'être let's talk a
little bit about kind of how you see the
bank playing with crypto right so you've
built this the cinnamon incredibly
valuable for folks but you're not a
crypto company right your goal legacy
regulated financial institution yeah you
look like a bank you smell like a bank
right you know you walk
banks oh yeah your bank ribbon and you
provide necessary infrastructure to
crypto companies alright and I think
there's two components that are
important one is that connection or that
support is a point of failure for the
crypto industry right right you know
we've seen in countries like India where
the regulator stepped in and said to the
regulated financial institutions you are
outlawed from working with crypto
companies well that doesn't sound like a
big deal except for now the crypto
company has no bank account to store
fiat pay employees et cetera to be very
kind of you know detrimental to their
business but do you just continue to
build financial services from like the
legacy world to support these companies
do you have ambitions to go into kind of
a crypto world and become more like a
crypto bank in the future kind just talk
to me sure knowing that you know there's
some stuff you could say around
regulation the regulars allow you to say
it so that you can't look for ludie
it's except they're like how do you see
this evolving over time as you continue
to support these 700-800 customers yeah
so first to touch on bank specific
regulation we would not be able to do
this were it not for the support of our
regulators right and and so the way that
looked from the very beginning was in
2014 as soon as we started banking this
industry we had a handful of customers
we invited our regulators in I can show
you a presentation the summer of 2014
that that we made to the state Banking
Department and the Federal Reserve and
it was essentially a Bitcoin tutorial
this is how Bitcoin works you know as
you know the graphics from the
distributed ledger and you know what
kind of stuff but but then we segmented
the market and it was obviously a very
nascent market and it still is but we
looked at it the same way then as as we
look at it today which is we said look
there's there's the different verticals
some folks are approaching Bitcoin as an
asset class you know as a new asset some
people are thinking about it as a
payment rail you know you can think
about like the bit pays of the world
that are trying to disrupt you know the
payment side of thing and we said
we're gonna you know we're gonna focus
on this institutional market and then
the other thing we're gonna do is focus
on other companies that are building
infrastructure or you know whether they
have to be protocol developers and you
know miners etc but what we're not gonna
do is kind of play in that middle space
which is the remittance space because
that's not how we're set up we don't
have a credit and debit card offering
you know so that that really wasn't
where where we wanted to play but
importantly back that back to your
question so so early on we explained the
regulator's this is how we view it these
are the these are the controls that
we're putting in place this is how we're
monitoring you know that the KYC AML etc
and by doing that I'm having that
dialogue with the regulator's early
prior to their next exam it allowed them
the opportunity to prepare for when they
came in to to do their annual exam okay
fast forward now for 2014 that was first
year 15 16 17 18 19 we just finished our
sixth annual regulatory exam right yep
we're not allowed to talk about
regulatory ratings but suffice it to say
we've been doing this for six years our
program has become a lot more
sophisticated I was telling you earlier
about you know looking at the you know
the blockchain to look at a specific
address to see a transaction you know
that was before chain alysus elliptic
you know cipher trace all these other
elements this Elementary's yeah it's
gotta get them on there thank you for
that you know so that was before all
these tools were developed which we've
you know obviously now incorporated into
our systems right and and so our process
has matured as you know as the ecosystem
has matured so as we move forward you
know we continue to build our program
and then we're essentially we're
customer driven everything that we do is
in response to our customers the sin was
born out of customer demand our you know
customer requests saying hey this is
it's painful to you know the banking
friction is painful and it's a lack of
liquidity the counterpart
risk and so really trying to to smooth
all that away that's how the center was
born now that we've got you know you
know growing towards a thousand
customers in this in this space our
customers are saying you know we love
the send for the US dollar
we love the send for again the send for
euro the same you know for the you know
British Pound Sterling the single or the
Singapore dollar etc so we're enabling
foreign currency exchange which is
something that subrogate never did in
the past right and so but we also
recognize our customers want to do it at
scale right they're all thinking about
scale yeah there's their scale and their
global right that is the two big
components that this industry probably
more than most guys when a business
starts on day once a moment exactly so
so so we stood up a foreign currency
desk earlier this year and we're in the
process of establishing all those
correspondent banking relationships
around the world so that so that we can
facilitate foreign currency exchange so
so that's the most recent product that
you know that that we've added the next
thing we're working on is credit doesn't
exist in this market right the way it
does in other mature financial markets
the concept of prime brokerage all of
these things that just kind of work in
the traditional financial system don't
exist in in crypto and and so one of the
things we're working on right now is the
ability to provide leverage to customers
who are long Bitcoin and and because of
the 24/7 nature of the market and the
24/7 nature of sin again I think we're
probably one of the only banks in the
world that has the capacity the
capability to actually do something like
this you can think of it as you know
kind of in traditional kind of margin
lending output margin lending in quotes
because we're not a you know bitcoins
not a security and you know we're not a
broker-dealer we're a bank so we're
looking at it as providing
collateralized lending which is what we
did we make loans and we like clatter
you know the collateral for these loans
is gonna be Bitcoin it'll be Bitcoin
only
for the foreseeable future because it's
it's the only deep market exactly but
that's something that that we're in the
process of launching a pilot this
quarter and and and so we're gonna do it
small to start with the same way we got
into this initiative you know let's
let's get some of the very our best
customers on both sides of the sand
right and let's they're already trading
with each other they're already
customers you know their customers are
the exchange their customers of us and
then let's figure out how we can offer
them credit and so we're working on that
right now
and then going into next year the other
product that we're working on is a
digital settlement offering so that we
can up to this point we've only touched
fiat currency okay and we are
contemplating also providing a
settlement service for the digital asset
inter so that'll be a game-changer we
believe because just as our customers
have asked us for you know they asked us
for the sand they didn't know what's
call it in nor did we they asked us now
for the sand for foreign currencies
they've asked us for credit they're
asking us you know hey we trust you with
this we trust you with our dollars you
know we'd love you'd also stand in the
middle of you know of the digital side
of the trade and and so we get all that
done and you know and it's a pretty
robust offering yeah absolutely
what do you think you've learned the
most since 2013 we first read you know
the Bitcoin white paper to today so six
years that's more than 50% of the
lifetime of Bitcoin bail because think
of it in that sense and you have built
some of the most important
infrastructure for this asset in this
industry but it wasn't traditional like
Bitcoin infrastructure right it was Lexy
bang stuff what would you say is your
biggest takeaway or lesson learned over
those six years yeah that's a good
question I would say first of all
recognizing that that word Bank okay so
and believe me when when when when you
catch the bug you know and and you know
I've heard people say go down the rabbit
hole you know whatever metaphor you you
want to use here and and then you happen
to be in this in this position to where
you have access to to all these you know
these oh geez there is a temptation to
want to run off and do all of this you
know oh you know [ __ ] is going to
solve cancer and you know you know it's
gonna cure cancer and solve world hunger
and and you know all those things to say
hey wait a second what can we do as
silver gate we're a California state
charted chartered bank member of the
Federal Reserve and we've got these
great customers who have real problems
that they'd like us to solve so with the
probably the biggest takeaway is is
let's let's stay in our lane okay but
hey that that Lane can be pretty pretty
broad we but we don't need to go out and
and do some of these other kind of
esoteric blockchain things we just need
to solve problems for our customers and
and as long as we're being responsive to
what our customers are asking us for and
it's legal and permissible for us to do
it then then we've got just an
incredible amount of opportunity and we
don't need to go out look for the next
thing so we're not you know we don't
have skunk works at the bank trying to
figure out gosh if we build this I
wonder if our customers will don't wanna
its rather just taking in all of it you
know what our customers needs are and
sifting through you know what what can
we really do to help for sure and so
we're happy to be recording this on a
day where google just announced that
they're going to start offering checking
accounts to a service Facebook's got
their Facebook page is separate from
Libra and we've obviously seen Squared's
the cash app etc and of all these
technology companies are pushing into
the banking industry what's kind of your
take running a bank that's been very
successful in a specific vertical right
now so you've grown very quickly how do
you look at the balance between these
large technology companies that for all
intensive purposes probably have better
technologists right just research
wise than most of the financial industry
the financial industry understands
finance banking regulations much better
than the tech companies like how do you
see this playing out over time
yeah so it's interesting the
announcement this morning by Google I
mean they were at least the article I
read The Wall Street Journal they were
very specific that they aren't trying to
be the bank yeah they're gonna partner
at least what I saw they're gonna part
of the city and with Stanford credit
union so so they recognize that they're
not a bank that and and and so I think
one of the biggest takeaways there is is
that what does Google have they have
distribution right
what does Facebook have distribution and
and so and we recognize that subrogate
we don't have distribution right now
we're certainly you're building it we're
building it and and in the institutional
market you know I would say where we're
building that distribution but the
distribution of having you know millions
hundreds of millions and billions of
retail consumer you know customers
that's just something that that that
really to your point the tech companies
are you know much better at building
those networks and and and so even when
Lieber came out you know or you know
when Libra was first announced and I
looked at the the initial members of the
Liebherr Association and okay well we
don't have a direct relationship with
Facebook but we've got relationships
with that company in that company in
that company you know and and so you
know if and when there's an opportunity
to to work with some of those folks you
know I think we're well positioned but
in the meantime we're gonna focus on you
know on solving the needs of our
existing customers and I'm pretty
confident that there will be an
intersection there at some point but
we're not going to try to compete with
you know with with the behemoths that
that that have you know all the
financial resources the tech
tech resources and the distribution yeah
and it's interesting because this is
Google's announcement comes on the heels
of the launch of the Apple cart right
which was Goldman Sachs and Apple coming
together and what I really took I
bounced in my head you know will you
call distribution I look at his
distribution is one component and the
trust isn't there right of like look I
trust Apple with my you know I my iPods
or whatever called I trust them with the
iPhone right I trust them with my
computer or etc why would I not trust
them with banking right and just plain
people say you know there's data issues
as privacy that you know there's all of
these potential concerns but for the
most part I think people feel pretty
positive about Google Apple Facebook etc
is this a world where the finance
industry is gonna need them to continue
to build trust or do you think that
there's folks like silver gate who they
start to specialize right so rather than
go really general and say hey we take
everybody from anywhere and that's our
focus we want to stay really broad right
which more of a kind like a JP Morgan or
wells type approach you guys have done a
great job of say look we were very very
specifically focused on this one issue
because we found a niche and we're the
leader and we're gonna double triple
down I'm guessing that there's other
verticals that you'll eventually go into
over time as well and kind of execute
that same strategy is it a thing where
you can get fast followed by the big
guys into these niche strategies or is
it just right time right place you guys
have happened to understand the problems
better and you can really build a moat
around you know certain industries and
then go try to replicate another niche
industries as well yeah so I certainly
think that the bigger guys can do the
fast follow strategy right and and and
so you know when you think about
competitive modes that the whole reason
in 2016 we hired Ben and said hey you
know we need to we've got something here
we need to figure out what we do next is
is because our first moat was the
compliance
you know the regulatory compliance piece
right but I'm not naive I I knew that
any any large bank could you know could
just grow a bunch of bodies at that and
replicate it and it wouldn't take
nearly as long as it took us because we
were doing it you know during our day
job you know what yeah as we're running
the rest of the bank so the sin became
our next competitive mode right and then
as you start to build a network effect
that you know you mentioned earlier the
network effect and and we really do have
like this two-sided network now right
where we've got you know the exchanges
and the OTC desks we got the
institutional investors and every time
we add a new institutional investor it
creates value for the exchanges every
time we have another exchange or OTC
desk it creates value for all the other
institutional investors so it's this
virtuous loop and and so do I think that
someone else can come in and replicate
that perhaps you know I I'm not I'm not
throwing the challenge out there you
know but but but the fact of the matter
is network effects are really difficult
to disrupt you know I mean why why is
tether so strong right I mean tether
just gets pummeled you know and and and
yet they've got four billion dollars at
least we think they do but in the
important thing is the market thinks
they do right and the market you know
and and so no effects you're just
incredibly difficult yeah now you also
talked about trust right
you can lose a network effect if you
lose trust right and and so now having
said that you know we've seen the
example with Libra but why is Libra come
under such attack because of some of the
issues with Facebook right and the
Facebook issue not a Libra exactly in
those cases yeah I think that spot-on
but even with that so with all the
issues people have you know with with
Facebook it's still a pretty powerful
force five hundred billion dollar
company I did okay yeah exactly so so
you know I mean do you feel like that's
a western-centric problem right like I
worked at Facebook so you know full
disclosure I'm I'm highly biased whether
I think I am or not but to me it feels
like the Twitter crowd the kind of
journalism crowd but you know very kind
of North American audience and we
to yell and scream and bring our
pitchforks out and say you know Facebook
sucks today stealing our data and all
stuff
my general take is probably people
outside the United States they're like
man face looks pretty powerful right now
it connects me to my friends and family
and and many many people in the world
they don't that's how they access the
Internet right yeah I mean they they're
accessing they're doing it with Facebook
on their phone right and and so yeah I
do think you know the the the West and
particularly the US yeah I mean just
just look at the you know at the at the
crypto Twitter you know Wars that go on
you know people love to take a position
and then you know come hell or high
water you know that's the truth you know
so intellectual combat yeah the
intellectual combat is very real yeah
yeah given out a was like purple hearts
on the outer for the intellectual wounds
that people take and and by the way on
that on that point you know how cool is
it you know so you so you got Jack
Dorsey who you know you know who founds
Twitter right and then Square and then
with the cash app comes full circle with
you know with square crypto and and
people are fighting about that on
Twitter you know yeah so it's why do you
bring him up I still think he is highly
underrated in the industry in terms of
how important he will become right so
he's important today for sure in terms
of Twitter obviously he built a platform
Square but he's recently been on this
kind of world tour he's been going
things in Nigeria the news in Ghana and
I think it's kind of gone through a
couple of African countries and he's
meeting up with folks and the only
things he's sharing out mine are these
Bitcoin meetups all right and there's
not a lot of people there right now
looks like there's seven or eight people
yeah but he's saying the time etc and so
I wonder a lot is that a is this a
personal social type trip right where
he's just going for fun is this hey I
want to understand my users on Twitter
and square right or is what I
immediately think through is you know
there's a world where actually
Westerners
or last to understanding the importance
of Bitcoin and crypto because we do have
banking we do have the dollar we have a
credit card right you know there's all
these infrastructure in place you know
African countries Asian countries South
American countries like there's a lot of
people who actually don't have that
something they'll write to them right
and if you think about the difference
between if I have to sign for a US bank
account and go through all the kind of
hoops and hurdles of doing that and to
buy a stock for example versus if I have
an internet connection I can jump on you
know finance or some exchange at that's
out the United States right and just buy
a - can I stock yeah the accessibility
and frictionless experience of going
with my internet connection on a crypto
exchange but may actually drive me to go
do that rather than go to traditional
route yeah and so do those other
countries leapfrog kind of us
infrastructures yeah right the kind of
is mobile banking all right yeah and so
I think a lot about just you know or
Westerners own was too spoiled to see
the opportunity ya know and and I mean
certainly in crypto that's that's that's
the case I think we're you know there
there are so many folks in non-western
you know the non-western world that that
kind of get what you know kind of the
some of the core underlying values that
an opportunity is with Bitcoin you know
the stuff that you were just
articulating and that's that's one of
the things so when I get philosophical
about this you know I I don't think that
bitcoin is going to replace the US
dollar right I don't think that it's now
could it become as you know the Bitcoin
standard you know could it could it
become you know kind of like the reserve
currency for for the world and and
replace gold certainly you know I mean
Gold's got a huge head start and only
5,000 years well yeah exactly but but
but yeah but if you think about it you
know I mean in a digital world you know
what other asset is there that has the
digital scarcity a bit coin now folks
don't understand it it's still early you
know but give it another you know a
couple of decades and it still will have
nothing compared to the 5,000 years of
you know gold but where things are
moving a lot faster now - yeah
for sure what um what's been the one
thing that you kind of sit back and say
in 2013 when I jumped into this I didn't
expect acts to happen like what's been
the most surprising thing of the last
six years well just kind of on a
superficial level the price right I mean
I bought Bitcoin in in 2013 as an
experiment you know I want to understand
how it worked and you know I didn't buy
enough because I didn't believe enough
you know but but but what I thought was
I thought wow so when I was I was
reading that I'm just thing called
Bitcoin everyone was gonna be able to be
their own bank and as I shared earlier
I've been banking my entire career and I
was like oh what am I gonna do myself
exactly and and so I thought I'm gonna
try this you know and and even though
I'm not you know I'm not a super techy
guy deep in the weeds I try everything
you know I just want to see how it works
and and so so I bought some Bitcoin and
then the price went up to a thousand
bucks you know
wow that's incredible and then the price
came back down I thought yeah okay so
but I did buy more you know because I
thought well heck I might as well just
you know I one of our are one of the
woman on our board of directors said you
know Alan we ought to just
each buy ten thousand dollars worth
Bitcoin just forget about it I wish I
would have done that in 2013 you know so
I did a later but but you know I bought
a lot fewer then you would have my side
so now yeah I was gonna buy if I was
gonna spend ten thousand today I'd only
get a little over one you know so anyway
so so the surprising thing I guess on
the one hand is is the price and and I
think it's got obviously got a lot of
room to run still but and then you know
I just the development of the ecosystem
I've I kind of missed the whole internet
thing okay I was you know that was in
the early 90s I was out of banking
and running companies and so you know on
the periphery I was hearing about the
internet but I was I was in I was in a
wholesale bakery doing a chapter 11
turnaround of this of this family-owned
operation in San Diego I didn't have
time to you know internet internet you
know you know I look back on some of the
actually something that you just wrote
where you were talking about I think the
you know the early internet early
internet yes and and you know hearing
the you know the dial tone you know and
seeing you know that clip from what sure
he's Brian Brian Gumbel yeah what is the
internet what's that accent more yeah
that a the circle around you know so but
yeah you know so it's it's been just
absolutely fascinating to be just be
blessed to be at the early stages of
this kind of revolution that is digital
currency yeah
and and it's pretty crazy to me I think
as you think through the impact that
this can have on the world right in
terms of the United States has been a
great beneficiary of things like credit
for example right right things where
people when they're given access to
financial services in terms of income
generation and and yield and an ability
to invest etc I always go back to just
as I did there's not a lot of people in
the wall and our percentage basis that
have that access right and so I spent a
lot more time now thinking about like
what I call income generating activities
so mining right right oh yeah I'm sorry
has somebody from Venezuela recently and
he's like look man you know the average
person doesn't make that much money here
right and guess what that money is
getting worse and worse in terms of the
hyperinflation etc but I can buy a
computer I can plug it in at home I
could turn it on with my internet
connection and now all of a sudden I'm
making money every month right right and
it's like more income supplementation
yeah and it really threw me down this
hole of like well what else can you do
with just an internet connection right
so you can do staking can do Mainichi
these interest accounts like start
looking and you're like look again I
don't think that it's gonna you know
completely solve the world's problems
right and you know global warming
disappears right I have to jump from
Bitcoin to global warming
but in terms of giving access to well
you and I would consider a kind of table
stakes Financial Services yeah it can be
really powerful for economic development
around the world and what I look at is
like when do the government's realize
this and say you know what maybe we
aren't the best at trying to drive
economic development instead let's
empower people to use these services get
connected to the rest of the world
financial you know industry etc it may
never happen or maybe it happens you
know somewhat in the short term but to
me it just feels like that's like
another inflection point that on boards
a lot of people very quickly it kind of
gets them into what I think is you know
this alternative financial system yeah
no I
I definitely agree with that concept I
don't see governments you know really
kind of pushing that right because
government you know so but if
governments can just kind of you know
not over regulated and let it happen I
think it can be very complimentary how
do you look at the regulatory
environment today in the u.s. with
crypto like you sit in an interesting
seat because you actually are more
regulated than almost every crypto
company or a given that you're you know
events they charter etc but when you
look out at the critical industry
there's a lot of people who say hey
there's uncertainty or the rules need to
change etc like you're probably the best
people would have an opinion wouldn't
you kind of think in terms of that
regulation in the environment today yeah
so so there's there's certainly
opportunity for you know for improvement
of the regulatory climate but what what
folks really need to understand is that
you know if you want to change the
regulation in in most cases you have to
change the law right regulations are
just written to and it to kind of
interpret and you know to and and you
know essentially enforce the law in a
certain sense right so when we when we
first got into this with what our
premise was well you know there are
existing regulations you know that you
know that determine how we're supposed
to treat our money service business
what type of KYC
supposed to do you know what type of
regulatory framework should these
companies have and one of the biggest
kind of filters that we use when we're
working with a with a new prospect
whether it be an exchange OTC desk you
know do they understand the regulatory
climate that they're stepping into right
and if they don't if they don't have a
view on which states they need a money
transmitter license on but in which
states they don't you know do they have
a compliance officer or is the
compliance officer also the CEO you know
I I mean in the early stages folks were
just really kind of coming up the
learning curve and it's understandable
because they were essentially software
engineers you know they were coming from
the technology world and all of a sudden
they had people banging on their door
saying hey you know you need to comply
with these laws and they say wait a
second I just created this you know this
this program to you know to trade
Bitcoin and and so we certainly had the
benefit being a regulated financial
institution and understanding regulation
it's just okay well let's let's figure
out how how the existing rules apply so
I don't I didn't by the fact that oh
this is the Wild West and it's not
regulated I've you know I said timeout
it's regulated you know which is people
people need to understand how it is so
now are there opportunities for
improvement certainly you know I know
there's a lot of concern about the you
know the state-by-state money
transmission licensing you know the fact
that that there is no federal you know
one you know but let me be careful with
you wish for right to have one federal
oversee here for all of that you know
there is something to be said about the
sovereignty of the individual states you
know and and the way the u.s. is set up
so so I think it's a mixed bag our our
goal is you know we're certainly happy
to enter into dialogue with regulators
and with politicians you know about how
things could be improved but those those
changes are probably going to be slow
and when we do get them where you know
again be careful what you wish for
so we're just gonna focus on what are
the rules and how do we you know how do
we comply with them might one of the
things might my wife teases me
that is when I was growing up I have
three three brothers I loved to play
board games and I I always read the
rules you know and and so I we just read
the rules you know and figure out what
are the rules of the game and you know
and that's that's that's how we got into
this business and that's how as we think
about new products and services you know
we have a relationship with the New York
DFS we're California bank right so why
would we have a relationship with a DFS
well because they regulate a lot of our
customers right and so several years ago
we realized you know what they should we
should know them and they should know us
and so we made an appointment and I
think initially they were like well what
was it was this California Bank coming
here but but we have a dialogue with
them and so as we think about perhaps
offering like the the settlement for
digital assets and perhaps not doing
that
inside the bank but maybe in a separate
licensed entity that would be a sister
company to the bank there's an
opportunity perhaps to do that here in
New York you know with with the DFS
we've got a relationship with the OCC
they regulate national banks but we've
been in there to talk with them you know
the FDIC comes in even though we're
we're a member of the Fed so the FDIC
doesn't normally come into a state bank
that's a Fed member because you only
have one federal regulator the FDIC
likes to come in to see what we're doing
you know and since they insure our
deposits what's that what's that crypto
yeah this guys are friendly with the
crypt of you what are they yeah so so so
we have a lot of dialogue with a lot of
regulators
speaking of regulators and lawmakers
there's a lot of talk now of a digital
dollar rights of the u.s. creating this
digital dollar any thoughts in terms of
good idea a bad idea or kind of how you
see that playing out yeah so so it's
interesting because in one sense and I
know this isn't what people are talking
about but in one sense it's already
digital right you know so that's I know
that's not what folks are talking about
but when you go to the 19 just to lose
that sitting at home 90 to 93 percent of
the money supply is not physical paper
or physical
coins that's right it's exist somewhere
in the digital world when people talk
about this quote-unquote digital dollar
what they're talking about is
essentially tokenizing tokenizing get
dollar and then you know essentially
making that though then a direct
obligation of the Federal Reserve as
opposed to an obligation from your bank
and that's and that's the primary
difference is when I I have a bank
account in silver game right and so
theoretically that's where my money is
breaking news and CEO of silver game has
a super-gay bank account okay well hey
but but that was important that gives me
confidence yes but but I'll I'll tell
you when I went when I when I bought my
first Bitcoin and I wanted to understand
the experience of buying it through an
exchange so I connected this in October
13 I connected my silver gate account to
my coinbase account that I had opened
online I wanted to see word where did my
money go you know and and so it I took
great comfort be the CEO silver gate
that I could I could really watch watch
the account closely you know so but back
to your question on the tokenize dollar
you know I I think there are some things
to figure out there right because the
whole credit system of the US you know
how do people get loans they don't get
loans directly from from the Fed they
get them from banks right and and why do
you banks you know so so banks are
essentially fueling the economy you know
in the sense of kind of that's how
that's how the government creates money
right his food is through the banking
system and if you tokenize those dollars
to where you don't have to go to a bank
but you can you can just do it direct
you know now all of a sudden there
aren't deposits in commercial banks to
fund the loans and and so I there's some
stuff to figure out there there's just a
lot of challenges in terms of that
there's almost like second and third
order effects of doing is you may solve
one problem but create another that's
right interesting
all right as we wrap up a rapid-fire set
of questions where do we think is the
most important company in crypto other
than silver gate you're one of the only
people coming here who legitimately you
may be one of the most important company
I joke with people usually but you
actually may run with the most important
guys what is it what do you think is the
most important company other than silver
date sure so I'm gonna actually go back
to our our very first customer I think
the digital currency group is is
probably you know because if you think
about what they do so they have three
primary businesses right so they have
Genesis trading where where they are
facilitating you know the buying and
selling of Bitcoin there they're also
doing lending right so they're they they
they've expanded their offerings so
that's one line of business there they
have greyscale which is the the way that
you know you can do institutional buying
you know of a you know of a regulated
security if you will you know of all the
different funds that they have and then
they've bought coin desk you know which
is the marketing arm but then
importantly they also then have
investments in there's probably the most
important piece from my perspective that
investments in around 150 crypto
companies so they're providing seed
funding and you know and assistance with
companies that are starting in this
ecosystem and so you know hats off to
Barry for the vision that that he had
you know and and you know and then thank
you I want to thank him too for sending
us some of those early referrals and
then I don't think we've mentioned this
yet but I but I should mention to you
now that I've said I think they're the
most important company but I actually
personally invested in digital currency
group back in 2015 when they were when
they were essentially selling
SecondMarket
they were going all in creating this
company called DCG the digital currency
group I thought this would be a great
way for silver gate you know to really
participate but I knew that the bank you
know talked about regulation you know
Bank was going to be able to itself make
an investment in digital currency goofus
I approached Barry and asked him if he
was doing a little thing friends and
family round and I wrote a very modest
check but but it's been
an incredible partnership you know to to
have an insight view and there's a lot
of stuff that digital currency group is
is going to be involved in that isn't
going to be relevant to silver gate and
that's okay but you've got a front row
seat yeah absolutely yeah is it screen
what about what's the one regulation
that you would change or improve if you
could I'm gonna stay away from all
banking regulation okay that's wrong
I actually think the you know the whole
concept of a de minimis amount of
Bitcoin you know that you can transact
with you you know folks I've talked
about like 600 bucks or something like
that I face this myself so I'm a whole
work you know I bought Bitcoin I just I
tucked it away but then when I wanted to
experiment with okay well what if I
wanted to set up like my own note I you
know want to set up a lightning note for
instance so I'm gonna go online on a bi
note okay well guess what I could only
do that with Bitcoin or lightning so now
I've got to go
you know either sell some of my Bitcoin
that I bought at a hundred bucks and pay
tax on it right or so I just bought some
you know so I just bought some new
Bitcoin you know but I mean so that was
like a $400 transaction then I'm gonna
put a tax on right and and so yeah it
just it's a huge discouragement I think
right to to making these small
transactions it's hopefully it gets
figured out what's the most important
book you've ever read so I could I could
give you a bunch of business books but
when you ask the question that broadly
I'm gonna have to you know say the Bible
it's it's it's the only book that I read
out of every day yeah so it's funny to
me how few people say the Bible yeah I
would think that that would be the most
popular answer yeah and most people
usually say you know whatever other book
sure I think it is for those that read
the Bible it probably is ya know it's
it's it's the only book that I always
have in you know I always I've got in my
backpack I read it every day and love
and so yeah it's awesome
what uh what about aliens
non-believer yeah so so oh he may go he
may go the no no no I'm not gonna go
with the no because it's certainly
possible right okay it's absolutely
possible I don't spend a lot of time
worrying about it you know now I love
you know I grew up you know enjoying
science fiction you have kind of stuff
and and so but it's just I mean there's
so much to do here on earth and and with
our fellow human beings that I don't
spend a lot of time worrying about you
know that's math you know so but is it
possible
absolutely it's possible or are you
somebody who would be more interested in
space exploration or ocean exploration
yeah so actually probably space that
exports okay so yeah so and and that
just you know I had a telescope when I
was little and I loved astronomy you
know and it fascinates me how and maybe
it is because we're little or whatever
but just the the human desire to look
out and go get up and kind of you know
space yeah we don't know what's
underneath the water like it just it
just strikes me as and again I don't
know if it's a human nature thing or
well but just there's not that many
people who say I'm very interested in
what's beneath the water right here on
earth but if you think about it and you
know I grant you that most of the earth
is covered by water but there are a lot
of people that that don't touch the
ocean you know but everybody everyone
looks up yeah it's very fair yeah what a
one question you have for me to end this
thing so what what do you think the most
important most important company and
quickly is I know you talk to a lot of
companies yeah I cheat so you've
probably been asked this question before
not not actually that often I say
Bitcoin yeah it's not a company right
but just the market is determined to be
the most viable it was the first it's my
joke and say it's like the first love of
anyone who comes to the industry all
right is the Oh Bitcoin got me here
right maybe they kind of go their own
path whatever but but that one will
always be there but in terms of
companies so that's what was my answer
some people push me like well you can't
say not a company yeah right now
and I'm always careful to say like this
chef see changes in my opinion or right
based on market dynamics time where
companies are people can fall from grace
right stuff right now I'd have to say
that finance is probably the most
important and I say important because
one it's one of the deepest liquidity
pools have not DD this it's also got
probably the most aggressive kind of
land and expand strategies so start with
a spot exchange and then it's quickly I
had you know futures and lembeh and also
the custom and then the third part and
probably the part that is most
underrated about the company that I've
started think more about cz and that
executive team are probably most open to
working with non-north American
countries so to really drive adoption
basically everywhere else in the world
right right and I think that there's a
lot of companies who say hey I want to
be in the US are be a us-based company
where I want to service US customers and
there's people who focus on China and
kind of Asia but there's a whole bunch
of countries that get left out South
America Africa you know Europe the whole
Middle East you know you kind of just go
through all of this and and if you look
at so the countries that finance is
pushed into it's not places that you
would normally think about yeah Uganda
right who's sitting there and they're
you know corporate boardrooms saying hey
what's our Uganda strengths yeah but for
whatever reason right then actually
maybe another story as to why that
became a place where they really pushed
in and kind of God wanna success but I
saw recently I think he people will
correct me on Twitter if I'm wrong on
this but I think he was in Uzbekistan or
somewhere right and kind of just these
kind of obscure places when you read it
from a corporate planning process but
there's millions of people who live in
these countries right they want access
to this stuff and so right now I think
they're kind of pushing the pace and
look they already either gonna be
successful or not but when you have
somebody out in front pushing the pace
like that everyone else playing catch-up
right so you kind of drive the
competition by
I think somebody who who's willing to
kind of go out there so for right now it
was this November 2019 I'd say by Nance
ask me in six months yeah cz don't mess
up brought the change so thank you so
much for doing this where can people go
if they want open an account at silver
gate or become a customer where can they
go silver gate calm in the legacy world
they have the dot-coms and they act like
normal companies yeah we're a company
that actually has to make money i I
won't say the name of the company but I
was looking for somebody's website
recently and I tried every you know get
at the mayor yeah yeah you know with at
the name the name app.com
like I'll try all these everything I
couldn't find it and Google wasn't being
helpful and it eventually ended up being
with the name of the company dot IO uh
and I was like that's no wonder I
couldn't figure that one and then here's
a very much enter on Twitter as well I'm
a Twitter at silver gate CEO alright
don't don't leave cuz they you know
change Twitter name that's right alright
now thanks so much for doing this
alright thank you